Chinese government is now waging war on  funeral strippers this coming from the  telegraph some communities in rural  China believe that bigger attendances at  funerals help to honor the dead bring  good fortune so then we're saying that  the erotic shows actually pay tribute to  fertility because their godless pagans  the Chinese Ministry of cultures new  crackdown campaign so that's actually  the Chinese Ministry of Culture yeah  involves people being now offered  financial rewards to this video  subscribe by clicking the button that  says subscribe if you're not aware of it  now there's no way you're learning the  Internet at this point I'm not going to  help you but this was clipped from my  daily show available exclusively to  lotto with credit com / mug club members  of your student military or veteran  entering that promo code it's less than  $6 a month and you get daily content no  more clips Plus this hand etched mug oh  I just when I feel it I got a chill like  on the inside